I hate intros attack on Titan season 2
we kick off the first episode with the
face of a Tyne being revealed inside of
wall Cena on zoe is baffled then pedo a
approaches her in a panic and begs her
to not let the Tyne inside the wall into
the sunlight the soldiers heed the
warning and cover the face with sheets
Zoe starts looking for answers from Nick
but is ignored she gets triggered and
threatens to throw him off the wall he
makes it clear that he's prepared to die
to keep his secrets she doesn't do it
and claims it was a prank bro a
messenger is writing to deliver a
message command to Edwin that there are
Titans inside of wall rows we then jump
back 12 hours to some familiar faces in
Connie Springer and Sasha but outs diner
Braun and his loyal companion battle
twofer are also on standby playing chess
Sasha hears footsteps me kaizuka Deus is
in charge in spots Titans he gives the
order to the side characters to get
their horses and weren't surrounding
homes and settlements since Connie and
Sasha are from the area they are charged
with being guides for the rest of the
soldiers connie agrees on the condition
that he can go to his village first
which is to the south and where the
Titans are coming from the Titans start
spreading out of nowhere it's Amica has
to go and slow them down
Edelin wakes up an uncontested wife who
was waiting for him with her trusty
scarf how do you mean comes in to
deliver the news that Titans are inside
of wall rows Rika comes into contact
with the B Stein who can talk and
control the nearby Titans the Beast time
wants to know about the maneuver gear
but Mika is too scared to answer so he
takes the maneuver gear and the
surrounding Titans kill me kid
episode 2 Sai characters were told they
were on standby but we're actually
isolated in case there were more Titans
like edit Ottoman has the theory that
the walls are made of Titan skin similar
to how a knee encased herself in her
shell the Recon Corps preparing to go
aid the soldiers inside wall rows and
find the breach in the wall they bring
Peto and Nick along in hopes that the
site of actual suffering from the Titans
will be enough to convince him to share
what he knows
Sachi guides the soldiers to nearby
villages to warn them she then proceeds
alone to the village where she used to
live a deep in the forest we get a short
flashback of her and her dad discussing
what to do in the future Sachi was being
selfish about the refugees from mom
Maria but he convinces heard that they
are all connected so she should care
more back to the president she comes
across the new village he finds a little
girl whose mom is being eaten by a Titan
Sasha tries killing ditalion but can't
break through its skin so instead she
has to make like pedo neck and escape
with the little girl she sends the girl
to safety and blinds the Titan with
arrows to slow it down
when she goes to find the little girl
she comes across her dad who was
bringing horses to people connie makes
it back to his hometown and everything's
destroyed when he goes back to his house
there's a time just kind of chilling on
top of it tightens legs aren't strong
enough to carry it so it's stuck there
but the question is how did it get there
if it can't move
episode 3 while investigating Connie's
home time they don't find any people or
blood they come to the conclusion that
they must have escaped before the Titans
got there but it's unlikely because the
houses were still destroyed and all the
horses were in the stables as they're
preparing to leave the crippled Titan
tells Connie welcome home you'd me it is
never away from could he's saying or
writing with the Western team who
evacuated people so now they're going to
ride along the wall to find the breach
ha Treecko makes her reappearance as
well as betta Hans a southern team with
Connie are following the wall through
the night and end up running into the
Western team neither side were able to
find a breach in the wall even though
they came from opposite directions they
need somewhere to rest so they had
system castle ruins for shelter so he
had been studying a piece of the female
teens hearts kid that didn't evaporate
when she compared it with the pieces of
the wall she found that they were near
identical so their plan is to use Eddins
titan to harden his skin and seal the
opening in the wall I don't it gets a
taste of the suffering spreading through
the land when press the talk again he
still doesn't say anything but he does
say that they were assigned a monitor
Krista diner had discovered something
about yumiya but before you can say
anything the castle ruins start getting
over ran by Titans they see the Beast
tying off in the distance heading for
the wall the soldiers prepare to engage
the tines but the side characters have
to just watch because they aren't
equipped to fight so he leaves a group
of soldiers along with Mikasa at Amina
and add into the abandoned castle so
they can assess the wall the episode for
the Beast tine climbs the wall and is
watching Titans assault the castle ruins
before the fighting starts we jump back
to ours Connie is talking about how the
Titan laying on his house reminded him
of his mom he met his jokes with him to
help him stop thinking about it
gladden her later runs into you mate who
was Kevin Ching for food and comes
across Amharic she comments on how she
doesn't like hanging but when diner
looks at the can he realized that the
label is in another language homazooma
Tana you
now we were caught up to the present and
the scouts engaged as heightens the door
gets smashed so side characters have to
go find a way to keep the Titans out but
I never in battle told hold off the
Titan until they kill it with a cannon
Conny put no points into perception so
that I know it has to push him to safety
he gets bitten by time but carries it to
a window so they can all push it out but
I know his arm is broken but he gets a
pretty nice consolation prize the four
Scouts are putting in work when a
boulder lands on the horses and kills
them all give the scouts go back to
check on the new recruits and they get
hit by another boulder and die instantly
the B Stein is hurling boulders toward
them in another large way of the Titans
attack having seen enough the B Stein
decides to leave the last two soldiers
are killed leaving just the side
characters left alive they seem to be
out of options so Yumi takes a knife
that Connie had and uses it to transform
into a Titan to protect everybody
[Music]
episode 5 we joke back aways to where
everybody was in training they were
doing winter training and everybody
makes it back fine but could I send you
me it away with DES and all three are
missing Eden and the others are ordered
to leave them and the rescue teams will
be sent out in the morning des was
injured so Kelis is pulling him through
the snow Emeritus trying to explain that
they will all die if she doesn't leave
him behind you may have come to the
conclusion that could he stay isn't
actually trying to save des police is
actually trying to commit suicide but
look like a hero while doing it you made
a confronts her about being a Nobles
daughter who's gonna be killed unless
she took on a new name enjoy the cadet
you may have had overheard priests
talking about the situation later join
the Cadet Corps and ended up finding her
your mere trust convincing her not to
give up her name and live life to the
fullest could ISA still doesn't want to
leave dad's behind those who you may
have to suggest throwing him off a cliff
near the camp in hopes that he'll
survive the fall choosing have been so
you mere throws her down a hill and she
gets covered by snow this allows you me
to transfer more into titan without
being seen and carry tests at the camp
jump back to the president we found that
you might have rolled the Uglies titan
in existence but she doesn't let this
stop her and she starts popping off on
all the other Titans but I near
embezzlers recognized you may have satin
because she had killed somebody close to
them in the past your mere tears down
the Terra so to land on all the tines
but it exposes everybody's safety this
kind of ends up backfiring because it's
not enough to keep the Titans down and
you made it ends up getting swarmed Zoe
the others show up and help fight off
the tines while adding gets his first
kill outside of his titanfall
you may had his badly injured in cleats
ends up rebuilding her name is actually
historian episode 6 you me it has lost
the leg arm and is in a coma but she's
still alive thanks to tiny attributes
releases full name is historia Dyson is
connected to a well known noble family
but I was pretty demoralized after his
injury and Beth told start saying that
they should just return to their
hometown huh shows up after searching
along the wall all night and reporting
that there isn't any breaches we all
prepare to head back to trust history
when diner pulls out inside and starts
saying that ham in bed float they're
actually the class on armored Titan
explaining that their goal was to wipe
out all of humanity but that can be
prevented if a dent agrees to go with
them to their hometown Eden feigns
ignorance but just twelve hours earlier
Zoe had received information about an e
laner or the female time both the diner
and better thought had come from the
same area as her which is suspicious but
not enough to convince anybody that they
were actually working together however
more things started to add up like when
the female Titan attacked the expedition
she attacked from the right wing then
your embed floats were among those who
were told that he was in the right wing
which was false information designed to
lure out Titans and spies I don't mean
then talked about when he meant I never
fought the female Titan on the
expedition but Einar broke free from the
Titans grass but afterward she appeared
to be looking at her pom possibly
reading a message from him after he
learned the Rope is
Nevada everybody's order to attack
naturally until they can get the both of
them underground back to the president
added into classy offer to go with them
in response that this round reveals his
broken arm healing Acosta's like open
attacks both of them which probably only
ended up helping Proctor transformations
the episode seven we come in with the
fight between edit and Reiner meanwhile
bill grabbed Umiat along with somebody
else and eat some so being the other
soldiers engage the colossal Titan
like before nobody can get close to
strike the vital because you really says
steam that burns anybody nearby
I didn't struggling because the strikes
aren't effective against Ryan's arm he
thinks back on his training with Annie
and her talking about fighting stronger
opponents with this mind he avoids a
head-on fight and takes riders to the
ground instead somewhere along the line
he learned some jujitsu and starts
putting the moves on him like a young
Gracie
he puts Reiner through a series of
submissions and ends up ripping off one
of her knees arms so we talked about how
an old armor a spot behind the knees
were weakened to target that to get some
of the side characters involved when
Adam puts him in a headlock Mikasa comes
in and slices the back of his knees
Brian realizes he's in a bad spot neden
is getting close to ripping off his head
so he pushes them to a strategic place
under the colossal Titan and releases he
yell the yell is a signal to the
colossal Titan to fall on top of them in
the last scene the colossal Titan is
breaking apart and starting to fall
episode 8 after the colossal Titan falls
on top of them Reiner gets the upper
hand he bites a tan out of his Titan in
bethel it's still had Yumi out of so he
escapes with Ryan we go to trois
district where pixies is turning up in
the middle of the day and talks with
that one about the current situation
most of the episode is pretty filler
asked with the flashback of the three of
them as kids getting into fights after
that we go back to the wall I mean casa
regains consciousness and she finds out
that Adam was taken five hours ago and
no one is pursuing them because they
need a lift to get the horses over the
wall beta Hahn says he's going with them
and he gets them motivated to go get
better which accused one of those
terrible scenes where they show each
character nodding one at a time yeah we
get it
you want Adam back we get it but I
digress commander Edwin brink slips for
the horses and while they're moving them
Zoe explains that they might have
stopped at the giant forest don't need
time to rise tower to the fight and the
treats will keep them safe from the
Titans I didn't wakes up the other three
but has no arms the last scene are the
soldiers moving out to try and reach the
forest before nightfall Yepez Odin died
so he stays behind because she was
injured while fighting the colossal
Titan she wants to ride to Connie's
village to investigate the time they
can't move she can try because of the
injury so soldiers offered to go for her
over to edit and the others who were
resting in trees and can't go anywhere
because they are surrounded by Titans we
find out that you made a news she was a
Titan but she actually doesn't know that
much about it how didn't know where
Reiner starts talking like he's a normal
soldier and doesn't know he's a Titan
everyone is confused except for better
Fulton he has to remind him that they're
both times we get a short flashback of
him and he embattled as Marcos being
killed during the boulder mission and
trots
marco was John's friend and Annie had
his maneuver gear which ottoman had
noticed and led to her being found out
as the female Titan in season 1 but the
theory with Reiner is that he loses
sight of what's real after pretending to
be a soldier for so long
what happened those battles how we felt
when he heard the story about Eddins mom
he said that he did feel sorry so even
though their Titans I guess compassion
isn't completely lost with them you may
it ends up asking about the B Stein and
even though they're clearly familiar
with him they don't reveal anything
your guess is that they're trying to get
to him because he's their way home when
I didn't ask who the enemy is you may it
is cut off before she can say anything
ratner's trying to convince her to join
them in exchange for Greece's well-being
since you me it only seems to care about
Cree says she agrees and doesn't give
any information to edit they see smoke
signals from the incoming soldiers and
just have to wait another out before the
Sun sets so the Titans can't move and
they can escape episode 10 the soldiers
that went to Connie's village on Zoe's
behalf discover a close resemblance
between Connie's mom and the disabled
tighten well discussing what to do next
we find out that Bethel has a thing for
Annie and I ship it but I hope he's
ready for the rough Titan sex because
she seems like the type when they're
getting ready to leave ed and tries to
fight back but without being able to
transform he's checked out which could
also be a thing for Annie so I'm
predicting a love triangle in the future
before he passes out he overhears umeo
talking about when she was a Titan and
how she wandered outside the walls for
over 60 years
you made a soon realizes that cookie
said probably came with the formation to
save them and she wants to go back to
take her what Renner doesn't want to and
you me it has flashbacks of her
childhood she was homeless and taken in
by some cult that claims she inherits
the blood of the king which is a
fabrication to increase the influence
over the followers the people end up
worshipping her and it's a nice change
so she just goes along with it but when
they get raided by soldiers everybody
kind of throws her under the bus and
blames her for the whole thing even
though it wasn't her fault she takes the
blame to protect the people as
punishment they take her and the people
in the call up on a wall it's not
revealed how but they do something that
changes them into Titans they then kick
her off a wall and she aimlessly wanders
around for 60 years this is when she
runs into Ryanair and kills his
companion she then turns back into a
human and returns to civilization and
that's when she hears about christa so
she enters the cadet corps to find her
you meet her threatens them saying that
she's going to take a tan if they don't
go back for Kitty stuff they finally
agree so when the soldiers arrived she
abductor
then they use the armored Titan to
escape with everybody else pursuing
close behind
episode 11 we come back in on the
pursuit and you made it goes to get
Chris out of her mouth with so much
alive going around you think it's a head
type but not one of the good ones one of
the bad ones that you watch for like
five minutes and you're like whoa when
you have to leave well this isn't
awkward you may have comes out of her
time to talk and explain sighs she's
following Reiner now throughout the show
it seemed like you may have wanted to be
with kitty said because they had things
in common she liked her but in reality
it was just to save herself she explains
that she stole the power of the Titans
from Ryan his friend when she killed him
and now they're gonna kill her to get it
back but on the other hand if she hands
over kitty said that maybe they'll be
more forgiving all along she was using
kitty says insurance to secure her own
safety
Reese is like cool story bro but we cool
and is willing to go with them to keep
her safe Evan wakes up to beta Hans
being more of a disappointment than
usual because she tries to get to Adam
but Ryan protects him with his hands
rocking Mikasa is fatal crazy ass since
she can't get to a den she targets he
made about his stop I could you made us
talk down because if she fights back
she's probably gonna die with her not
fighting they can focus on getting a tan
back we get a nice reunion between the
characters the side characters reminisce
and ask if everything they shared of us
just lies but it doesn't seem like
they're doing this by choice even though
they deceived everyone it still seems
like they care about them Edwin somehow
got in front of them and is luring a
huge pack of Ty and stored them which
stopped the armored Titan
the soldiers are ordered to retrieve
Eden and while doing this Edwin gets
bitten by Titan and loses Azad
well trying to get to a demi Casas is
also injured by Italian but John save
sir Ottoman arrives and starts getting
in their head saying how can you leave
Annie behind and makes up this story
about her being tortured that loses that
right before he stabbed by one-armed
Edwin because of them retreat said in
what Connie and Sasha get could ista
could he still wants to go back for you
made but they won't let it Reiner starts
throwing tightens to slow them down and
stop the horses Eren and Mikasa are
knocked up and then we get the second
reunion of the episode with the time
that killed Eddins mom he episode 12
eden is tied up so when the time tries
to kill him in Mikasa Hans has to save
them Gracie goes back to you Mia and
they both agree to live for themselves
and fight together
Mikasa cuts had him free but he can't
transform to help Hans because he hasn't
fully recovered yet Hans tries to hold
his own but ends up getting eaten once a
beta always a beta Mikasa to his wife
betrayed spike and then realizing he
needs to encourage further waifu
behavior stands up to the time but when
he does is something happens in all the
nearby tie-ins attack the Titan who
killed Hans apparently I didn't has
something called the coordinator which
allows him to control nearby Titans this
is why Reiner wanted to abduct him so
badly
Edun yells at Reiner that he's going to
kill him which triggers the Titans to
attack Reiner with the Titans distracted
the soldiers are ordered to retreat you
may it ends up staying behind though to
help Brian your fight all three make it
out alive and get to safety on top of
wall Maria Connie and Zoe report that
it's likely there was no breach in the
wall and that the Titans were actually
people from Connie's village so all the
times are assumed to be people it's a
bittersweet fact that gets some one step
closer to the truth
bike a didn't really ends up game
oh hey Mira Casa de now that won't fight
together because it can we can say one
line one line in I couldn't get one line
in awesome awesome having fun themselves
and fight together patrol nearby zombies
all three make it out alive and get on
me Casas trip hmm them as a souvenir
said that think you can nearby tines
attack the tight oh come on actually
people from Connie's village a Dennis
tied up so when the time tries to kill
him in Mikasa haunts us to save them
Casey goes back to you Mia and they both
agree to live for themselves and fight
together
Mikasa cuts had him free but he can't
transform to help Hans because he hasn't
fully recovered yet Hans tries to hold
his own but ends up getting eaten once a
beta always a beta Mikasa to his wife
betrayed spike and then realizing he
needs to encourage further waifu
behavior stands up to the titan but when
he does says something happens in all
the nearby tines attack the titan who
killed hans apparently Eddin has
something called the coordinator which
allows him to control nearby Titans this
is why Reiner wanted to abduct him so
badly
I didn't yells at Reiner that he's going
to kill him which triggers the Titans to
attack Reiner with the Titans distracted
the soldiers are ordered to retreat you
may it ends up staying behind though to
help pry on your fight all three make it
out alive and get to safety on top of
wall Maria Connie and Zoe report that
it's likely there was no breach in the
wall and that the Titans were actually
people from Connie's village so all the
times are assumed to be people it's a
bittersweet fact that gets someone step
closer to the truth